[Music]
in clock mountain news
pop mountain the mountain of clocks
submitted by ducked out honda all right
hello Jeff Bezos is building a gigantic
42 million dollar clock inside a
mountain he's just bored at this for it
is so ballin he doesn't know what the
[ __ ] to do at this time
Wow yes he does actually the mountain
yeah 42 million dollar clock sure how
about you [ __ ] save the world with
that you come back or give it to me how
about you find a way to flash the Batman
sign on the moon that's pretty dope
I really do I swear more productive you
know what people who have that amount of
excessive money how come they don't
think about giving it back to people cuz
they know that people are dumb and
they're gonna ruin themselves everybody
I'm not just saying it just to say it
like if I'd legit had 80 million dollars
right I wouldn't need literally like 90
percent of that [ __ ] like I what do I
need that for at that point I would just
do it to help people you just go through
the go fund knees yeah I mean if you
think about Bill and Melinda Gates oh
yeah they are like even in the past I
was it Rothschild no no no there those
geysers I said no but uh there's there's
this it was like a tycoon that ended up
building the most libraries in the US Oh
Carnegie I think it's Carnegie yeah cuz
there's Carnegie Hall Library Hall all
these things and there are people in the
past that that that were super [ __ ]
rich but it still didn't really change
that much well this project here they're
calling it the ten thousand year clock
and Jeff besos Amazon CEO he's funding
this clock along with other people but
he's the one that's giving the most
amount of money which is 42 million
dollars oh [ __ ] what's the total price
of this clock yeah I thought that was
the whole thing that's the thing like
the kids can't read it anymore cuz they
can only read digital
it's architecture what's that silikal
yeah the way that reporting this is like
a 42 million dollar clock but then
they're also reporting that that's how
much he gave so I'm not sure but this
clock is a project of the long now
foundation and it's being built inside
of a mountain in West Texas but as if
enemies clock that's why now so four
vessels here he's investing in the
project because he believes that
humanity humans need to plan for beyond
our lifetimes and so the whole purpose
of this clock here is that it's it's
designed to run for 10,000 years and so
every time it hits a new millennium that
it will have like a cuckoo tone and so
he's saying that mountains gonna come
crumbling down and [ __ ] like ten times
throughout the life of this clock it
will be closed it like solar powered or
what no so it's powered by this large
weight hanging on a gear that's how its
powered so this is what Jeff this is the
same quote we humans have become so
technologically sophisticated that in
certain ways were dangerous to ourselves
it's going to be increasingly important
over time for Humanity to take a long
term view of its future over the
lifetime of this clock the United States
won't exist whole civilizations will
rise and fall new systems of government
will be invented you can't imagine the
world no one can that we're trying to
get this clock to pasture that's dead I
like that it's like a pyramid I bet you
like back there they did that for
something similar reason yes like a last
for all the time permits on one of the
gears of the clock Jeff kisses yeah I'll
show you guys a clip of it being
constructed it hasn't been finished yet
but they're saying that once it is
finished people could come and visit it
I wonder if the metal will survive that
long yeah here we go because one meteor
or just the rust and stuff
[Music]
is it already dogs so wait you can see
the clock from the mountain side that's
the thing I'm not sure we're inside the
mountain you have to discover it it's
inside they've been saying that it's
inside but like the actual face of it I
don't know where yeah I guess it's like
no different from what people did back
in the day like the pyramids the Great
Wall of China you know it was ten that's
what I want to see stone structures I
want to I want to get that henge
yeah but you know we can't even do that
[ __ ] right now with the technology that
we have we can't even move those like
huge a stone why it was aliens maybe one
of the theories is sound technology they
[ __ ] you sound to lift and levitate
Wow that's tight what would we can't we
can't create pyramids like that no we
can't move the with the equipment that
we have we can't move some of the stones
like of these mega structures like
there's that wall in Jerusalem I think
it's called the [ __ ] I forgot but it's
the one that everyone goes and praised
you but they have like these a crying
one there's like a huge huge like base
stone and they're like how the hell did
they get that there no one knows cuz you
can't it's like a thousand tons or some
[ __ ] it's like crazy big hmm yeah what
it feels already been yeah so I was
thinking and they built the wall on top
of it I've been even like the pyramids
where they're able to get many of those
in like in the geometric shape it's
crazy
you can't even slip a paper through them
yeah and they've also calculated the
physics where they know if they stack
all these layers of stone they knew the
physics of how strong the stone at the
bottom has to be so that the weight of
it won't crush it aliens aliens cuz
Dells during a time when people were
like Stone Age so they're like how can
this be Stone Age technology well they
had the humans have more strength back
then but the aliens had alien smarts and
so they were like we're gonna make these
human slaves and then they would hybrid
with one of them and that would be a
pharaoh that's why Pharaohs had all this
like crazy right yeah so their head
shape is like all like this but they
wouldn't live very long so one of the
most ancient civilizations in Sumeria
it's like around Iraq and stuff I think
it was the first
like civilization that was pretty modern
or like pretty advanced and they in
their religion they say that humans were
basically by bio engineered by aliens
yeah that's why things like already
failed at this body you [ __ ] my
angles exploded my knee exploded youth
[ __ ] I'm 11 we're all evolving down
because of science like you know if you
think people shouldn't be like able to
survive with being blind but we've
created glasses so now everyone's just
like I'm blind mating to be less weaker
but smarter but weaker I will say this
though I am one of the things I do watch
on YouTube a lot is just I call a human
like physical excellence you know what I
mean
just to watch like people who are
physically capable than other people
that you just can't obtain yeah I mean
no matter how hard you work or try you
will not get to that level you could do
the same amount of time but this person
was just born a little different yeah
and that should always [ __ ] amazes me
just even like like like martial arts or
something right you see it like how this
person throws a jab versus this person
they could have trained the exact same
amount of time but the way this person
punches is so much faster Francis in
Ghana he was homeless and then now he's
knocking fools out in the heavyweight
division it's just he's just the way
he's Bill he's meant to throw power
punches defenses in Ghana he just set
the record of the world strong his punch
and you would think he must have been a
boxer since he was 5 years old and
trained and perfected the technique he's
just built that way he was homeless for
the longest time he started training
upon in the UFC for a year and now he
has the world's strongest punch and he's
just laying [ __ ] out that's why
I like watching I don't know what I'm
for yeah everyone's probably built for
something right yeah you know I came
across this article of this little
twelve-year-old girl that knows how to
like she broke a record because she
performed for like more than six hours
singing a hundred and two songs and a
hundred and two different languages and
so she was just saying like and she just
picked it up a year ago and she was just
like you know everyone or you just have
to try thing and then reincarnation
figure out what you're good at
everyone's good I'm a big proponent
about like people just finding out what
they're good at and I think a lot of
people chase dreams to find out what
other
people are good and they want to imitate
it yeah you find what you're good at and
the [ __ ] smashes I'm really good at
binge watching that Netflix shows that
like everyone is genius at something
like oh yeah just gonna find me yeah but
what happens is it's weighted
differently like so we only as a society
give credit to like academia genius you
know where we're like oh these
scientists are geniuses and then we like
make them make it so bad they'll got
blue balls they can they can speak about
anything and we treat them like they're
genius at whatever they're talking about
but they're only genius at that one [ __ ]
those [ __ ] us so when they like
talk about I don't know politics or
whatever like they don't know people
revere them as being all of this let's
look at their bank account I bet you
they ain't got money yeah yeah that's
it's true cuz it's it's like what we
value as a society and then they say
that depending on what era you know what
was important to culture in society at
that time if you look at their
structures like what did they dedicate
their energy on building what like
before it was religion right huge
temples huge cathedrals and things like
that now it's the financial institutions
huge skyscrapers dedicated for
accounting firms and oil companies or
whatever and now his big-ass clocks and
mountains right so basically you can
right now it's just everything is
valuing money so it all goes down that
route like oh if you're rich you're a
[ __ ] millionaire you're a rock star
or whatever and you work so hard that
you don't value emotions you don't value
social life you don't all that stuff is
like laziness yeah overworking is is the
best right now yeah that's true
you're hustling you're staying on the
gradually everyone's got the highest
rate of depression right now the highest
rate of anxiety now actually kind of
want to start like the anti I mean I'm a
big fan of Gary Vee but in like but all
those like hustler type of entrepreneur
like podcasts I kind of want to start
like an anti version of just telling it
was be lazy just relax don't pursue your
boroughs
you find yeah I just have balance it's
okay that's ultra successful are you
gonna just be like yo I'm gonna stop
here yeah I'm a pulse like once a year
this is way to a successful right now
[Music]